hey guys how's it going it's Justine and
Jenna I am so excited because in this
video today I am going to be baking you
the most fantastic cookie recipe that
you are ever ever gonna see has anyone
seen your videos it's never that good
which means that on my channel I'm gonna
be cooking a better cookie so national
cookie day is right around the corner on
December 4th and to celebrate we are
participating in the first annual
holiday cookie jam bake-off I'm gonna
win this is great know whoever wins this
competition gets their cookie recipe
that they made in their video in the
game and I'm so excited because these
cookies look absolutely incredible
you're inspired by the game if you guys
want to vote for our cookies you can
head over to Facebook comm slash play
cookie jam and you can also download
cookie jam on the Google Play Store or
the App Store it's free and you don't
even need Wi-Fi to play but what you do
need Wi-Fi to do is to watch this baking
video and vote for my cookies
my cookies and can you guys imagine how
incredible this would be to see my
little cookie right here alongside all
these other cookies anyway let's start
baking today we're gonna be making
rainbow sugar cookies with chocolate
frosting and I'm going with a chocolate
frosting to kind of play off the cookie
GM logo much like the rainbow cake that
I did before the chocolate frosting and
the rainbow and I'm hoping that'll title
together and that will entice you guys
to vote for me please please I thought
we would use the pink mixer today
playing off of the rainbow theme I also
have my wonderful rainbow would you like
me to stop moving so you can put got my
beautiful rainbow Apple watch it's
actually it's too big for my current 38
millimeter watch but that's okay I'm
still wearing it anyway
so for the cookies we're gonna need 1
cup unsalted butter 1 cup of granulated
white sugar 1 teaspoon vanilla extract
1/2 teaspoon almond extract 1 egg
two teaspoons baking powder three cups
all-purpose flour all right now that we
have all of our ingredients let's let's
assemble this hot mess and get these
cookies started this is kind of softened
but I feel like I might need to make it
a little bit more warm so I'm gonna pop
these in the microwave and then we're
going to cream the sugar and the butter
together I think that's good enough
looks good to me oh wow wait and we've
got our sugar put that in just like so
okay let's start mixing this up can you
plug it in make sure you always lock
your mixer if you guys don't you should
coz I've made some mistakes you just
turn down I'm gonna make sure this is
all mixed in there everything's off the
bottom so next we're gonna beat in the
eggs and the extracts now we've got our
butter and sugar mixture we're going to
work on our dry ingredients how many two
teaspoons of baking powder because I'll
just mix this in with this
this works oh now we're going to slowly
mix in our dry ingredients into the
butter mixture very very slowly here we
go
super-exciting
oh yeah
let's just get in somewhere now it's now
we have our day already we're gonna
borscht with us out into six different
little sections and then we're gonna
take each of those portions and we're
going to dye them different colors so
let's get out some saran wrap and we're
gonna portion this out I'm concerned
that this might not be enough but I
guess we can just see what happens if
you need more you can always make double
this recipe didn't you little dough go
to your home
wonder what this tastes like mmm Wow I
think I put too much bomb and extract it
but I like almonds so this is good oh
wow mmm I'm definitely gonna win don't
forget to vote for my cookie at
facebook.com slash play cookie Jim all
right that's portion a sucker out a
little bit of you a little more of you
this looks like a little dinosaur look
at him Wow so the first color I'm gonna
do is purple because why it's one of my
favorite colors much good Jam that in
there and this dye is Wow it's powerful
just drop some of that in there
[Music]
there he goes it looks perfect like look
at that that's all I had to do it's not
gonna go through wait to die the rest of
these and you know what I just need to
lighten the load a little bit I need to
feel a little bit better about what I'm
gonna do because this takes a lot of
time because every time I do a color I
then have to freakin reset because I
don't want to mix in the other dull
colors so gosh the struggle maybe I
should just quit YouTube and just start
juggling okay let's roll get in there
[Music]
go little buddy go
so now we have our dough all colored I'm
marking off some parchment paper so I
know the size of the dough to roll this
will make sense in a second please hold
now we're gonna be rolling the dough on
top of a fresh piece of parchment paper
because you don't want to be rolling
dough directly onto Sharpie because I'm
not sure if you guys realize this or not
but sharpies not edible surprise so you
can see pretty clearly our little square
that we've got marked off you can
basically make this any size but since
the dough that I rolled out wasn't very
much I don't want to make it too big or
I will run out we need to make an egg
wash now I googled this because I didn't
know what it was I'm going to be putting
the egg white in between each color so
that'll kind of help it all stick
together when it bakes it's now we need
an egg white so we're gonna put a little
the egg whites in here with a very touch
of water
get yourself a baking pan like this I'm
gonna line it with some parchment paper
as well so the first color we're gonna
do is all red so basically gonna be
rolling it out to be about size of this
okay so this looks like it would fit in
the square and now we're just gonna be
cutting along these lines - I left the
lines a little bit longer so you can
just kind of cut along those just like
so and that will give you a nice even
little triangle this isn't it your ankle
its right so we've got a rectangle here
and now we're gonna be placing this over
here and then we're basically gonna be
repeating this five other times which is
Wow doesn't that sound like fun
flip it over
plop it down so I'd recommend kind of
like cleaning this off between each one
because some of the color may transfer
on to the other color and that's
something that you do not want so the
next time we're gonna do is the I guess
gold orangish color get this square off
[Music]
now before we put this on to here we're
gonna put that little egg whitewash on
top of it okay you're just gonna kind of
brush it on real nice real nice now we
just put this oh god no no no no don't
do it don't you break don't break on me
buddy you could do it good to be very
careful everything looks good and we're
basically gonna be going through this
whole process and learn all of these
colors on top of this little guy and I'm
gonna just press it down just a little
bit there you go
okay now we're gonna repeat this process
four more times so let's go
[Music]
it looks so great like I'm so excited
I'm gonna press this down just a little
bit to get them all kind of sorta you
know making friends make friends you
guys are gonna be spending some time
together would you take a look at this
so I put this in the fridge for about 30
minutes to an hour while I'm making the
icing and then I'm gonna cut this in
half and put this half on top of this
house so that we can make even more
cookies out of this little slab and
drink my dear but mati I'm gonna clean
up and then we're gonna start the icing
so one two three clean now it's time to
make our icing this is a pretty simple
recipe I've never made it before it
looks simple so it could potentially be
difficult I don't know first we're just
our they're unsalted butter we need a
cup witches two six if you didn't know
so we beat the butter on medium speed
until creamy it says approximately two
minutes but we'll see maybe that'll cut
down on the speed we can do it for one
minute
I think I'm gonna turn down for for what
couple for the next ingredients we've
got cocoa heavy cream this is a lot of
stuff I just don't know how this is all
gonna work out let's just start dump it
no it said slow I can't mess this up I
have one job literally one job
I'm just staring at it just waiting
waiting patiently or something to happen
it's put on the rest of the screen
Wow look at this this is great
mixie Wow
there's a lot of stuff in here I usually
see a store-bought icing but I thought
today I'm gonna class it up cuz I'm
really gunning for your votes in this
contest so I want you guys to be real
proud of me for doing it all by myself
I'm set the icing off to the side let's
take a look and see how the cookies are
doing our slab has been cooling for
about say probably an hour or so so I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna cut this in half
and I'm gonna place these top half on to
this half so that'll give us a lot more
to work with like take a look at that
look how great it is Wow so now we're
gonna place that on top of here I lost
my my things so I'm just gonna just do
that don't worry I wash my hands so many
times that like my hands are cracking
can you get this as even as possible it
looks beautiful
so here's the rough part is because it's
not exactly even so I'm gonna kind of
just cut this all off to make it nice
and even just so sad
so we're basically gonna be just like
cutting out the center of this I can
probably do it oh yes look at that now
is the magic so what we're gonna to be
doing is we're gonna be cutting a very
small little slice of this and that's
we're gonna be using for the template of
the cookie so we'll be sliced this it
creates a nice little rainbow effect we
use this and we do this and then wallah
follow along at home this is a very very
simple thing I definitely encourage you
to try this don't have to do it first
cuz is it the deepest I think I think
that's how the song goes here's our
first lab we're basically just gonna
keep repeating this until we don't have
any more left one single cookie
[Music]
we have a lot of effort for very very
little reward it's like life 10 cookies
and this took me like like five hours so
think I'm gonna cook these for about
eight to ten minutes Alexa set a timer
for eight minutes
we're lathis bake and then we're gonna
ice them up and hope that everything
works out well I can't believe how much
time that took so we've got our I think
about our cookies in the oven everything
is actually going very very well and
very according to plan so I'm quite
surprised and also nervous so what we're
gonna do is we're gonna prep for the
icing I'm gonna put it in an icing bag
because I kind of want it to look as
good as possible know what's coming out
of the side well awesome of that okay
we're taking them out now I can't chance
this I can't chance this Alexa stop this
is my life's legacy cookie jam these
look so great I'm so happy here are the
rainbow cookies now we're gonna fill
these things with our homemade chocolate
icing and we're gonna make some cookie
sandwiches this is it this is everything
this is I think I'm to put more icing in
it but it's a good start this is a good
start I'm into it I'm real into it okay
next one we're gonna get five whole
cookies that's a lot of icing oh my
goodness good here we go here we go I'm
high man I'm high this is what the hype
train looks like choo choo baby how is
anyone ever gonna be able to eat this
like there's no way let's see which one
will I try I think I will try this one
he's a little guy Oh work probably oh my
gosh the only thing that would make me
happier as if I could eat this cookie
while playing cookie jam while my cookie
is in the game I feel like that's some
crazy inception nonsense
alright I'm gonna go let me know what
you guys think on my cookies leave me
some comments below and let me know if
there's anything else that you guys
would like to see me bake don't forget
you can check out cookie Jim in the App
Store and the Google Play Store I'll put
all the links in the description and of
course a link where you can vote for my
cookie I'm gonna go finish this cookie
in peace while I play my game piece can
you just come here and give it a little
sniff sniff the competitor come sniff
the competition baby whatta look better
with white icing ah yeah
[Music]